[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نص صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
الهواتف المحموله خطر دهم بوتن في كيب
ويدامه في مكيف كارسيا لم تتعلم الدرس
تحقيق لرويترز يكشف المزيد من التفاصيل
حول خيوط روسيا الانقلابيه في المانيا
شخصيات الرئيسيه باسماء مستعاره
الجمهوريون يكتبون التاريخ لكن بالسلب
يفشلون في اختيار رئيسي مجلس النواب خمس
مرات
والسادسه على الطريق
كاميرا العربيه تتابعوا اضرابات بريطانيا
في يومها الثاني من داخل احدى محطات
القطار
وسوناك يريد حوارا معقولا لانهاائها
[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
ضربه قويه تلك التي تلقتها روسيا في
مكيفكا اليوم ارتفع عدد ضحايا الهجوم الى
89 هذه هي الحصيله الرسميه وكل يوم تتكشف
اسباب الهجوم والمزيد من تفاصيله اليوم
اكدت الدفاع الروسيه ان الاستخدام المكثفه
من قبل العسكريين للهواتف المحموله هو سبب
الهجوم بعد ما كشفت مواقععهم
ما تنساش يبرين يربط
التميسك لكن من الواضح بالفعل ان السبب
الرئيسي لما حدث له والاستخدام المكثف من
قبل افراد الفوج للهواتف المحموله ما
جعلهم في متناول اسلحه العدو وسبح هذا
للعدو بتحديد احداثيات مواقع الافراد
العسكريين لشن الضربه الصاروخيه يتم حاليا
ممثله في المستقبل نتيجه
ان كان حدثا فرديا يمكن ان لا يكون امرا
جللا لكن عندما يتكرر يصبح الوضع خطيره
تقرير سابق لنيويورك تايمز نشر او نشر
الاف المكالمات التي اجريت في مرسى الماضي
بين الجنود الروس وعائلاتهم حينما حاولت
مفقود دخولك لكن كان هناك مستمع انه قوات
انفاذ القانون الاوكرانيه التي كشفت مواقع
الجنود
سبعه
ونص
وعلى الحديث
صوتيه للخدمه العسكريه
اود ان اشكر اولا وقبل كل شيء المختصين في
مجمع الصناعات الدفاعيه الذين ابتكروا
وبدوا الانتاج الدخل لهذا السلاح الفريد
كما قلت بالفعل لا يوجد مثيل له في اي
دوله في العالم انا متاكد من ان هذا
السلاح القوي سيسمح لروسيا بحمايه نفسها
من التهديدات الخارجيه المحتمله بشكل
موثوق وسيساعدنا في خدمه المصالح الوطنيه
لبلدنا
بينما تتواصلوا المعارك على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه يجد الكريم للنف نفسه في
مواجهه سهام انتقادات داخليه بات في مرمى
الانتقادات كما تحدثنا بالامس وتحديدا بعد
حادثه الاخيره مع هدوا دراسات الحرب تحدث
عن محاوله الرئيس الروسي العظيم
مصدر ازعاج حقيقي
الكريم لن يستخدمه عده طرق لكسب ووده
هؤلاء المنتقدين وهم على العموم مدونين
يتوفرون على الاف المتابعين فالبعض منهم
ما تم الدعوته الى برامج التلفزيونيه على
اساس اشراقهم في النقاشات الدائره حول
الحرب هذا فضلا عن تقديم عروض لابرام
صفقات مثل انشاء برامج على مواقع التواصل
كما حدث مع مشرفينا على قناه
تيليجرام ريبار التي كانت توجهت انتقادات
للطريقه التي تدار بها الحرب
واكانت الانتقادات والداخليه قد ازدادت
حده على خلفيه هجوم ماكيفك الاخير الذي
خلف عشرات القتلى في صفوف المجندين الروسي
اخر المنتقدين المدون العسكري المعروف
سيميون بيكو الذي انتقد الروايه الرسميه
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه التي القت اللون
على الجنوب
[موسيقى]
متابع من دنياتك ومن كيف من دمياط العربيه
رائد الاخبار ومن كيف حذيفه عادل مرحبا
بكما رائد ابدا معك جديد التطورات
الميدانيه وهل هناك اي اجراءات اضافيه
اتخذها الجيش الروسي خاصه فيما يتعلق
بتعليمات للجنود بعد ما تكشف من معلومات
حول استهداف
صهيب من الواضح ان الايام الاخيره
ارتفعت فيها وفيره الاعمال العسكريه
بالقصف المتبادل ما بين الطرفين الاوكراني
والروسي كما اننا نلاحظ هنا في دنيتك
ارتاح العسكريه وتنقلات لها في محاور
مختلفه لا سيما بعد الضربه القويه الموجعه
للجيش الروسي بعد قصف مركز تجميد في مدينه
ماركيكا بالفعل اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه عن
الاعداد ثم اعلنت عن ارتفاع هذه الاعداد
ويارا بعض الخبراء والمحللون بانه نوع من
الشفافيه اعلان الخسائر فيما لا تعلن
الاطراف الاخرى الارقام والخسائر التي
تعرضها روسيا بشكل يومي حيث ان روسيا تقصف
مثلا اليوم قصفت مركز في مدينه درونكا في
مختلطه عدنان قالت بانها قتلت اكثر 200
جندي اوكراني وكذلك همم من المرتزقه
الاجانب كما وصفتهم اضافه الى تدمير اربعه
صواريخ اربعه منصات عفوا صواريخ هاي مرزو
والنشاط صواريخ التشيكيه ايضا كما اسلفت
ادخال الفرقاطه التي تحمل صواريخ ساركون
الى المجال العسكري كما ان حشد امريكا
قوات على اطراف رومانيا نحن نقترب من
مواجهه كبيره ووجيها اا ليست مواجهه ما
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا انها مواجهه ما بين
الارض و روسيا
همم يعني
هذا ما تقوله صحيح رائد يذهب مع التحليلات
والمعطيات التي تؤكد ان روسيا تستعد همم
لتعبئه جديده لتغيير مسار هذه الحر ساعود
اليك همم فيما يتعلق همم نقطه اخرى ولكن
لا يسال كذلك حذيفه عن الاستعدادات همم
الاوكرانيه بعد هذه الضربه الموجعه التي
اوكرانيا للجيش الروسي في ماكيفكا همم ما
الذي همم قامت به اوكرانيا حتى الان همم
من استعدادات وكيف تتحضر ربما للرد الروسي
المنتظر
نعم مساء الخير صهيب لك ولزميلا رائد في
الحقيقه دعني ابدع بهذا العاجل الان بحسب
كريم تمشيكا نائب رئيس ديوان الرئاسه
الاوكراني فانه هنالك قصف كبير الان واسع
نطاق على منطقه في دونيسك هذا القصف بدا
قبل قليل قبل دقائق فقط وهو مستمر حتى
الان ايضا انتقل طبعا الى حديث الرئيس حول
المحادثه الهاتفيه التي جرت بينه وبين
الرئيس الفرنسي والتي شكره فيها وقال ان
الرئيس الفرنسي وافق على نقل الدبابات
خفيفه الى همم اوكرانيا وايضا ناقلات
الجنود المدرعه والجيش الاوكراني يعاني
حقيقه من نقص في هذه المدرعات هذا من جانب
طبعا اذا تحدثنا عن الاستعدادات من الجانب
الاوكراني فان همم طبعا الجيش الاوكراني
ان يتوقع هجوم عنيف من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
ولكن في ذات الوقت صهيب الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه تتحدث من امرين اولا
ان مخزون الصواريخ بالنسبه للاتحاد الروسي
هو يقل بنسبه كبيره ولا يستطيع ان ينفذ
ضربات واسعه النطاق التي كانت في بدايه
يعني منذ حوالي شهرين همم ومنذ بدايه
الحرب حتى قبل شهرين كانت يتم اطلاق 100
صاروخ دفعه واحده 120 صاروخ دفعه واحده
الان الاتحاد الروسي في هذا الوقت هو غير
قادر الا اذا امر لصفقات جديده او انتظر
حتى يكون هنالك مخزون جديد من الصواريخ
كذلك الطائرات المسيره اخر صفقه للاتحاد
الروسي كما قال الرئيس الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيا كانت 250 طائره مسيره
هو استخدم نصف هذه الكميه حتى الان لذلك
سوف يستخدم دفعات صغيره من 30 طائره سيكون
الهجوم مقسما حتى يستطيع الحصول على صفقه
جديده او على طائرات جديده اما الان الوضع
واا محاوله فرض السيطره هي في منطقه في
منطقه سوليدار وكذلك في منطقه همم في
خوفقه وفي هذه المنطقه يحاول الجيش الروسي
سيطرته وهذا ما سيحاول ان يقوم به بحسب
الاستخبارات العسكريه في الايام القليله
القادمه نعم رائد اود اليك في عجاله هذا
القصف على كراخوفك همم كما ذكرت انه ال-
ال- استهداف الجندروس هو وقع ليله راس
السنه ولكن الضغط يزيد على همم الروس مع
تكشف المزيد من التفاصيل وارتفاع عدد
ضحايا من الجنود الروس هل هذه فقط يعني
بدايه الرد الحقيقي همم ما يزال همم يتم
التحضير له ام ماذا
تحركاتها في المنطقه كما ان زميلي حذيفه
تحدث عن تقدم روسي في مناطق
منطقه سليدار غابت قوسين او ادنى من ان
تكون تحت سيطره الجانب الروسي كذلك
همم يعني نصف خلال او تطويق من ثلاثه
جوانب لم يتبقى للجيش الاوكراني هو
الانسحاب من الناحيه الغربيه ربما ايام او
شهر لا نعلم لكن محاور اخرى في جنوب دانيه
كيف ان يتقدم فيها الجيش الروسي ويدفع
القوات الاوكرانيه كما ان الاله العسكريه
الكبيره تقصد باستمرار ولا ننتظر الفكره
الجيش الروسي بدا بالعمليه منذ اربعه ايام
منذ تلقى الضربه في ليله راس السنه وكل
يوم يقول عن اعداد كبيره يتحدث عن اعداد
بالمئات من خسائر الجيش الاخراني بالفعل
العمليه العسكريه همم الاكبر المعركه
الكبرى وام المعارك
باتت وشيكا لكن همم اخيرا اضيف بان
المقارنه ما بين حجم القصف الاوكراني وحجم
القصف الروسي همم يصل الى تسعه الى 1
لصالح روسيا شكرا جزيلا لكما رائد الاخبار
من دنيتك وحذيفه عادل من كياف
ومدينه باخ مو 30 تحدث عنها مراسلنا قبل
قليل لا زالت عصيه على الجيش الروسي وهذا
الاستعصاء جعل الانتقادات التي تحدثنا
عنها تزيد للمسؤولين الروس الذين باتوا
مطالبين بتوضيح الحقائق للمواطنين وللجنود
يبديني بريجوزين رئيسه مجموعه الروسيه خرج
ليبرر للجنود اسباب الفشل حتى الان في
الاستلاف على مدينتي
مهمته قوات اا فاجنر ليست بالسهله في ظل
التحصين الجيد للجيش همم للجيش الاوكراني
وهذا السبب الاول في وجهه نظري قائد السبب
الثاني هو ان الرجال باقي لنا وحدهم
يقاتلون في هذه الجبهه
بريجوزين عفوا اكد ان المهمه قد تستغرق
بعض الوقت وقال للجنود نصر تنظيف المنزل
طويله
اختراق الدفاع يعني اختراق دفاعي منزل
واحد ثم عليك ان تكسر دفاع المنزلي التالي
اليس كذلك هو ليس مجرد خط دفاع واحد كم
عدد خطوط الدفاع الموجوده اذا قلنا 500
فسيكون ذلك دقيقا اليس كذلك
[موسيقى]
في خدمه التجمعات التي تشدها المانيا ضمن
حملات احتجاجيه لافراد يطالبون بتغيير
سياسه البلاد اوكرانيا
الشهر الماضي تواصل تحقيق لرويترز على ان
شخصيات الرئيسيه في هذه الحملات لا هات
صلاته اما بالدوله الروسيه او باقصى اليمن
لم تكن المؤامره الانقلابيه التي كشفت
عنها المانيا حدثا عابرا فلا تزال خيوطها
تتكشف يوما بعد يوم تحقيق لرويترز كشف عن
علاقات تربط شخصيه رئيسيه تقود حركا في
المانيا بالدوله الروسيه او باقصى اليمين
التحقيقات ابرزت ان هذه الشخصيات تدفع
بموقف مؤيد لموسكو داخل المانيا منذ بدء
الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا الامر يتعلق
بظبط سابق في سلاح الجو الروسي وكان يطلق
عليه في الاصل
وغير اسمه الى ماكس لندن استقر في المانيا
قبل عقد من الزمن والثاني يدعى
ويتعهد بالولاء الاسلاميين الشرقيين الذين
يدعمون حمله موسكو العسكريه في اوكرانيا
في حين يتخذ اخرون بعض الاسماء المستعاره
ولديهم علاقات غير معلنه مع روسيا
والكيانه الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبه الدوليه
او بمنظمه اليمين المتطرف
وينشر بعض النشاط الموالينا لروسيا رسائل
الكريم لاين على الانترنت للجمهور الناطق
بالالمانيه تحليل رويترز وجد لقنوات
تليغرام باللغه الالمانيه مالا يقل عن 27
قناه تعيد باستمرار مشاركه الرسائل
المؤيده للكرملين الى جمهور مشترك يبلغ
نحو مليون و500,000 شخص بلال الوجداني
العربيه
[موسيقى]
تجاوزت حدود القوميه والجغرافيا ولا
تقودها ارادات محدده لذلك استمرت بخلاف
الاحتجاجات السابقه وفقه قوله الرئيس اوضح
لموقع ايران انترناشونال التركيز واشنطن
لم يعود على احياء الاتفاق النووي خاصه
منذ شهر سبتمبر
انا وانتقد المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران
روبرت مالي قمع السلطات للمحتاجين الشباب
وقال في تغريده الله انه يتعين على
القياده الايرانيه الاستماع للشباب بدلا
من قتلهم واشار مالي الى ان الشباب
الايراني يواجه عقوبه الاعدام بعد محاكمات
سوريه
اضرت صور متداوله ليس معلومه الوقت
تصويرها انتشارا كثيفا لقوات الامن
الايرانيه والحرس الثوري في شوارع مدينه
سميرم في اصفهان في محاوله لمنع خروج اي
تظاهره ضد النظام
[موسيقى]
في ما يبدو انها محاوله لتهدئه الاحتجاجات
اكد المرشد الايراني علي الخامنائي اهميه
مشاركه النساء في عمليه صنع القرار في
البلاد واكدا انه يجب ايجاد الطريقه
لتطبيق تلك المشاركه ونقلت وكاله الانباء
الايرانيه الرسميه
قوله ان توظيف نساء ايران الذين او
اللواتي وصفهن بالحكيمات والخبيرات في
مختلف في مستويات صنع القرار في البلاد
موضوع يحضر بالاهميه وعلى القاده في ايران
تحقيق ذلك
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه نتبع من مصر
الجنيه المصري في ادنى مستوياته امام
الدولار وشهادات ادخاريه بعائد 25%
للسيطره على الوضع
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد الكونغرس الامريكي بدون
رئيس لمجلس النواب بعد وذلك بعد ما فشله
خمس مرات في التصويت المشهد لم يحدث منذ
قرن من الزمن دوله التصويت الاولى الثانيه
الثالثه الرابعه والخامسه من لم تسفر عن
فوزي المرشح الجمهوري كبر المطافي
الاغلبيه والسبب معارضته اقليه داخل
والجلسه السادسه تجري الان في هذه الاثناء
نتابع لقطات مباشره اذا الان من مجلس
النواب الامريكي اذا الذي يحاول التصويت
لاختيار رئيس لمجلس النواب طبعا همم
بيزعامه جمهوريه لان الجمهوريين حصلوا على
الاغلبيه في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
السابقه التي تجرات في شهر نوفمبر الماضي
همم قبل ذلك كانت الديمقراطيون همم هم همم
في الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب وبالتالي همم
الرئيس كانت منهم وهي سيبي لوسي والتي
عرفت بعدائها الشديد لدونالد ترامب
وعدم وجود رئيس لمجلس النواب من شنهي ان
يؤثر بشكل واضح على عمل المجلس فبدون وجود
رئيس لا يتم تمرير القواعد الجديده لمجلس
النواب وفي حال عدم تمرير هذه القواعد قبل
الثالث عشر من يناير الجاري فان لجانا لن
تعمل بشكل كامل للتعديل والموافقه على
مشاريع القوانين اما بالنسبه لللجان التي
لم يعرف رؤسائها فسيت راسها مؤقتا اكبر
نائب جمهوريا عاده ما يكون انتخاب رئيس
مجلس النواب اجراءا شكليا حيث لم يفشل اي
رئيس في الفوز في التصويت الاول منذ عام
1923 اي مئه عام بالضبط يعني
وتعد هذه المره الاولى التي لا يتم فيها
التصويت اذا على رئيس مجلس النواب من
التصويت الاول وذلك كما ذكرنا منذ العام
1923 فما الذي حدث حينها نتعب
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء انتقد نائب الجمهوريه دان كريم
شاو بشده كل النواب الجمهوريين الذين لم
يصوتوا على مكارتي لتراس مجلس النواب
معتبرا انهم جمهوريون بالاسم فقط
نتابع مع مراسلنا من واشنطن كير غانم كير
اهلا بك معنا ما جوهر الخلاف بين
الجمهوريين ولماذا يعترضون على مكارثي حتى
وصل الفشل في التصويت للمره الخامسه
والجثه السادسه تجري الان
لو اخذنا الامور على ما تظهر عليه لا بدا
واضحا ان هناك 20 شخصا من الجمهوريين في
مجلس النواب الامريكي يعتبرون ان الحزب
بشكل عام ومكارته بشكل خاص لا يسيرون في
سياسه ترضي ناخبينها وهم يعتبرون ان هؤلاء
الناخبين في دوائرينهم يريدون منهم ان
تكون هناك ميزانيه اقل ان يكون هناك اصول
مختلفه له اداره الجلسات وان يكون التوجه
الحزب الجمهوري مختلف تماما ويكون اقرب
الى هذه المجموعه المعروفه بالمجموعه
الحريه البعض يعتبرون كما ذكر احد اعضاء
مجلس النواب قبل قليل ان المساله هي مساله
شخصيه اخرونا يعتبرون ان هذا المعسكر هو
معسكر ترامب ولكن من الواضح ان هذه
المجموعه هي المجموعه عقائديه تريد ان
ترضي ناخدها وليس قياده الاسد
نعم ارجو ان تبقى معي سنتابع ما ذكره
ترامب الذي حاول التاثير على الجمهوريين
قبل ذلك اذا المشاهدين الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب دعا الجمهوريين الى
دعم ترشيح كيفن مكارثي لمنصب رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي ترامب خطب الجمهوريين على
تروت سوشيال لا تحول نصرا عظيما الى هزيمه
عملاقه ومحرجه
ومن جهته قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايد ان
اخفاق الجمهوريين في انتخاب الرئيس لمجلس
النواب يعاكس صوره سلبيه عن البلاد
العربيه ايضا في تصريحات صحفيه عن امله في
ان يتمكن الجمهوريون من الاتفاقي واختيار
الرئيس
فير لماذا لم يفلح ترامب في التاثير على
هذه الاقليه الجمهوريه التي تعارض
انتخاب مكارثي رئيسا لمجلس النواب
يجب ان نقول ان هذه المجموعه هي مجموعه
عقائديه وهي بدون شكاه تبدي تايدا للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ولكن عقائديه هي ليست
ملتزمه بدونالد ترامب تعتبر انها ملتزمه
بافكارها وملتزمه ايضا بالناخبين الذين
ارسلوا هؤلاء الاشخاص الى مجلس النواب
الامريكي اللي يرضوا هؤلاء الناخبين
ومطالب هؤلاء الناخبين لذلك نستطيع القول
ان دونالد ترامب فشله في زحزحه هذه
المجموعه عن موقفها اقله حتى الان
نعم فقط انا استمع اليك بيير واا
ابقي عيني عن كذلك على ما يدور في جلسه
مجلس النواب هناك تصفيق الان ااا لا نعلم
اذا كان هناك يعني هو مجرد تصفيق على احدى
الكلمات ام هناك اي مؤشر ايجابي للتذكير
مشاهدينا ان هذه هي الجلسه السادسه في
المحاوله السادسه اذا لانتخاب الرئيس
لمجلس النواب الامريكي بعدما فشل المجلس
في التصويت بالاغلبيه لصالح كيفن ماكرتي
يبدو انها همم ان الكلمات تتوالى اذا طيب
همم اسالك كذلك عن اجرائيا الان نحن امام
همم يعني همم حدث لم يحدث منذ 100 عام في
الكونغرس في مجلس النواب الفشل في التصويت
لصالح رئيس المجلس من الجلسه الاولى الوضع
اذا استمر على ما هو عليه ماذا سيحدث
ليس هناك مجلس النواب يعمل وبالتالي ليست
هناك قوانين ليست هناك اللسان وليس هناك
عمل في مجلس النواب الامريكيه الكونجرس
بالتالي هو كونغرس معطل لان اي قرار
يصدران مجلس الشيوخ يجب ان يذهب ايضا الى
مجلس النواب الامريكي عمليا العمليه
الدستوريه معطله الى ان يكون هناك رئيس
لمجلس النواب ولو اخذ الامر اسابيع
الغانم شكرا جزيلا لك وعلى العموم جلسه
التصويت السادسه مستمره في هذه اللحظات
سنوافيكم باي تطورا يرشح عنها
[موسيقى]
من امريكا اذهب الى بريطانيا يستمر قطاع
النقل البريطاني في اضرابه لليوم الثاني
على التوالي تمديدا بتردي الاجور وغلاء
المعيشه ويتوقع ان تتسبب الاضرابات وهي
الاكبر منذ ثلاثه عقود في اضرابات كبرى او
اضطرابات الكبرى لحركه القطارات بعد ما
احدثت اضطرابات في الحركه خلال فتره
العائله وكان الامين العام الاتحاد
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الى الجلوس مع
النقابات من اجل التوصل الى اتفاق نهائيا
حول مطالبهم معتبرا انه من حق العاملين في
الخطوط الاماميه اخذوا مخاوفهم من الاوضاع
المعيشيه في عين الاعتبار
ومن جهته قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني لكن
حكومته ستكشف عن تفاصيل النهج الذي ستتبعه
مع النقابات العماليه خلال اليومين
المقبلين داعيا النقابات الى التحلي
بالعقلانيه في اضراباتها واكيد سوناك انه
مستعد للحوار مع نقابات لكنه حذر في الوقت
نفسه من ان طلبات النقابات لا يمكن تحمل
تكاليفها عرب عبد الحق
دعوا لندن تعود الى العمل هكذا كان دعوات
الالاف من اللندنيين في ثاني يوم من
اضرابات بقيه النقابات وتحذر منها طوال
الشهر الماضي لكن مع اسرار الحكومه
البريطانيه على التمسك بموقفها الرافض
لطلباته عمال النقبات انا لا انا لا يلوح
في الافق لانهاء الازمه التي تتسع رقعه
اضراباتها محطه موتر له واحده من اكثر
محطات لندن ازدحاما بالمسافرين لكن مع
اضراب اكثر من 40 الف عامل في قطاع السكك
الحديديه تبدو هذه المحطه على غير عادتها
هذه انا نسبيا بعد الغاء العديد من
الرحلات
وفي خطابه الاول هذا العام نقابات الى
التحلي بالعقلانيه مشيرا الى ان
الاضطرابات رغم احترامه لاهدافها الا انها
اصبحت تعرقل حياه الناس
ورغم تعهد سوناك بالعمل على خفض التضخم
وتعزيز نمو الاقتصاد وفتح حوار مع
النقابات الا ان تعهداته الاقتصاديه لم
تكشف عن خطه واضحه لكيفيه تحسين اجور
العمال
اليد اعتقد ان الزياده بالنسبه 19% لا
يمكن تحملها وتشير استطلاعات للراي الى
تراجع دعم اضرابات السكك الحديديه الى اقل
من النصف بينما لا يزال نحو 66% من الناس
تتفهم اسباب اضرابات في قطاعات اخرى مثل
الممرضين وموظفي
الاسعافات وتخريبيه اكثر من كونها مفيده
ولا بد من التعامل معها بعقلانيه نحن
بحاجه للمال والكل بحاجه
يؤثر على الجميع
دخل البريطانيون العام الجديد بكل سخم
لكنهم لم يجدوا لندن مستعده لهم اضرابات
وقطاع السكك الحديديه هي البدايه لسلسله
من الاضرابات التي تهدد بها النقابات ومع
وعود غير واضحه من الحكومه في تحقيق مطالب
العمال يبدو ان بريطانيا مقبله على فتره
صعبه من غير الواضح خطوره متابعتها على
البلاد من لندن عيوب عبد الحق العربيه
[موسيقى]
نذهبوا الان الى مصر حيث سجل سعره صرف
الجنيه المصري تراجحا قويا جديدا امام
الدولار حيث قيمه البنوك الدولار الواحد
عند السته وعشرين جنيها و 45 قرشا ياتي
هذا تراجع نزولا من مستوى
24.70 جنيه للدولار في تعاملات امس وتعد
هذه اكبر خساره يوميه للجنيه المصري منذ
ان سمح للبنك المركزي بنخفاضه بنسبه 14.5
في السابع والعشرين من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي وجاء الهبوط بعد قرار بنك مصر
والبنك الاهلي المصري صباح اليوم طرحه
شهادات لمده عام بالعمله المحليه بفائده
تصل الى 25%
البنك الاهلي وبنكو مصر وهما مصر في
المملكه للدوله تحركها لاصدار شهادات
استثمار مدتها سنه بفائده 25%
الهدف وهو اغراء حائز الدولار بتحويل ما
لديه للجنيه للاستفاده من هذا العائد فهل
سيقبل البعض عليها
ويجيب شهادات من اللي هي الجديده
اسعاره هتبقى متوازنه في السوق في المرحله
المقبله بعد اثاره هذه الشهاده
بانه بدايه التعويم الثالث لهذا العام
ووصفه اخرون انه دليل على مرونه سعر الصرف
في التماهي مع العرض والطلب
هذا تراجع في قيمه الجنيه امام الدولار
دعى البعض للتشكيك في مدى اقبال المصريين
على هذه الودائع تحرك اسعار الصرف او
انخفاض الجنيه كان مقيم اكبر بكثير من
الشهادات اللي طرحت يعني احنا اعلى شات
تقريبا طرحت كانت 18% ما زال هو اللي اتجه
للشهادات هو برده ما قدرش ان هو يحافظ على
ثروته او
الممتلكات بتاعته مقاومه الدولار
من شانها ان يكذب المصريين للتخلي عن
الدولار مقابل عائد مادي مجزي ولكن في نفس
الوقت هذه الفائده المرتفعه تقول الكثير
عن الغلاء المتوقع في قادم الايام تباينت
توقعات الشارع حول معدلات التضخم في
الفتره القادمه
مش مستنيها شهادات دي بتعمل المصريين
هيحطوا مبالغ كبيره هيحطوا مبالغ كبيره
جدا في البنوك فالنقد اللي معاهم في يديهم
هيقل فاعتقد ان دي هت- كنترول شويه في
اسعار السلع يعني الحكومه المصريه وكانت
قد اجلت تحريك اسعار المحروقات والكهرباء
كنوع من التخفيف على المواطنين وبالتالي
فهناك ترقب للاجتماع القادم للجنه
المسؤوله عن تحديد سعر الوقود لان هذا
ايضا يشكل عاملا هاما في تحديد تكلفه
السلعه ومن ثم في تحديد اسعارها تامر نصره
العربيه القاهره
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الصحه العالميه
تشكك بارقام الصين حول انتشار كورونا
والمانيا تدعو لاخذ زياده الاصابات على
محمل الجلد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد بالعوده الى الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه كريستيانو
الهدف الواحد لكل الجنسيات هدف واحد هو
اذن لكل الجنسيات المختلفه
[موسيقى]
ربنا
دراما
[موسيقى]
ممكن فراوله
الى الصين هذه المره التي توصل ابهارها
العسكري وتسير نحو اطلاق التجارب الاولى
لحمله طائراتها الجديده سفينه فوجان
التجارب ستكون الاولى من نوعها لحامله
الطائرات الاكثر تطورا في تاريخ البحريه
الصينيه والتي تعد ايضا اكبر سفينه بحريه
صنعتها الصين على الاطلاق ويراهنوا الجيش
الصيني بشكل كبير على حامله الطائرات
لتعزيز اصوله البحري وياته اطلاق هذه
التجارب استكمالا للخطه التي اطلقها
الرئيس
لتاسيس الحزب الشيوعي الصيني والتي تقوم
على تحديث المعدات العسكريه وستكون هذه
الخطوات الاولى في سلسله من التجارب تستمر
حوالي 18 شهرا على ان يتم تشغيله حامله
الطائرات الجديده بحلول اكتوبر 2004 2024
[موسيقى]
اخر مدير عام منظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس
اكد ان احصائيات الصين حول اصابته ووفيات
كورونا لا تعكس حقيقه انتشار المرض في
ارضها
وكانتينيو
اكثر وبشكل سريع وموثوق حول اعداد
الاصابات والوفيات منظمه الصحه تشعر
بالقلق ايذاء المخاطر على حياه الناس في
الصين ونؤكد على اهميه التطعيم واخذ جرعات
اضافيه لتعزيز الحمايه وهذا مهم بشكل كبير
خاصه لكبار السن ومن يعاني من حاله طبيه
معقده الذين هم اكثر عرضه للاصابه
والعواقب الكبيره
اما الاتحاد الاوروبي فقد اكد انه تم
الاتفاق على تقديم القادمين من الصين
لنتيجه اختبارنا وفرنسا من الدول
الاوروبيه المؤيده لهذا القرار
لاوروبا لا توجد دوله تريد ان ترى فشي
المرض على ارضها ليس بعد كل الجهود
والتضحيه التي بذلت على مدى سنوات الثلاث
الماضيه اعتبارا من الخامس
48 ساعه الزاميه لجميع المسافرين القادمين
من الصين هذا اجراء منطقي لحمايه
المواطنين
اما المانيا التي عارضت القرارات
الاوروبيه فشددت وزيره خارجيتها ان
لينابير بوك على ضروره التنسيق المشترك مع
منظمه الصحه العالميه بشان مواجهه اوروبا
لموجه كورولا القادمه من الصين
هدفنا ايجاد حل مشترك ويجب ان نتعامل مع
هذه الموجه القادمه من الصين بجديه فارغه
ولن نتحدث عن تعاون الاوروبي فقط بلد
تعاون مع منظمه الصحه العالميه ايضا من
اجل الشفافيه الكامله حول الوضع في الصين
الرئيس الامريكي جو بادين اعرب عن قلقه
ايضا من تعامل الصين مع انتشار كورونا اما
بكين صاحبه الشان فقد اكدت ان الحكومه
والشعب سيحققان نصرا نهائيا على كورونا
حسبما نقلت صحيفه الشعب اليوميه الناطق
باسم الحزب الشيوعي الصيني انتقد الصين
القرارات التي اتخذتها بعض الدول التي
اشترتها على الوافدين من البكيين تقديم
نتائج السلبيه لفحص كوبرد
المدير العام للاتحاد الدولي الجوي كان في
صف الصين حيث انتقد وضع قيود على سفر
الصينيين وقال ان هذه التدابير اثبتت عدم
فاعليتها سابقا
الشوارع الخاليه
المكاتب الهجينه المطارات المقيده
سيناريوهات تعيد الى الاذهان ذكريات لم
يتجاوزها كثيرون حتى الان والعالم لن
يتحمل مثيلاتها مره اخرى حسب خبراء
تدابير لا يريد الكثير من الناس التفكير
بها ولكن الاجراءات التي فرضتها بعض دول
العالم على القادمين من الصين اخيرا
قعدتها الى الواجهه الصين بدورها هددت
بتدابير مضاد
كنت هون
للتواصل مع العالم للتغلب على رائحه كرونا
لكننا نعتقد ان قيود الدخول التي فرضتها
بعض الدول على الصين تفتقر الى الاساس
العلميه
لاتحاد الدولي للنقل الى التعليق حيث وصف
هذه الاجراءات بالمخيبه للامال
البيت الابيض يرى بدوره ان هذه الاجراءات
مجرد احتياطات لحمايه المواطنين وهي مبنيه
على قواعد الصحه العامه واتخذت بعد
استشارات مع خبراء من عده دول اجراءات
اختبرها العالم
لثلاث سنوات مضت بين ان الانظمه الصحيه
والاقتصاديه تعلمت من هذه التجارب واصبحت
اكثر خبره في التعامل مع هذه الانواع من
الازمات وفق ما يرى خبراء الصحه والاقتصاد
وتتحدث عنه الدراسات التي اجريت بعد ان
ضربت الجائحه انظمه واقتصادات الدول في
مقتل نحن نتبع من باريس حيث بات الغناء في
محطات المترو وشبكاتها في باريس مجالا
منظما يخضع لقواعد تؤطره ويجذب عشرات
المغنيين الهوايات الراغبين في البرازيل
موهبتهم ومنذ العام 97 بدات هيئه
المواصلات المدنيه في باريس بمنح الرخص
في فضاءات المترو وذلك بعد خضوعهم لتجارب
في الاداء
[موسيقى]
نهايه اخبار الساعه تذكيرهم بابرز
العناوين
الهواتف المحموله خطر داهم بوتين في كياب
ويدامه في مكيفكا روسيا لم تتعلم الدرس
[موسيقى]
تحقيق رويترز يكشف المزيد من التفاصيل حول
خيوط روسيا الانقلابيه في المانيا شخصيات
الرئيسيه باسماء مستعاره
الجمهوريون يكتبون التاريخ لكن بالسلب
يفشلون في اختيار رئيسي مجلس النواب 5
مرات
الكاميرا العربيه تتابعوا اضرابات
بريطانيا في يومها الثاني من داخل احدى
محطات القطارات وسوناك يريد حوارا معقولا
لانهاائها
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء